bismillah alhamdulillah assalamualaikum
which is greeting a peace peace be unto
you thank you for tuning in to another
episode of the Deen show today we're
going to be talking about hip hop with
our guest Napoleon from the Outlawz
which was a group that was alongside
with Tupac Shakur's so when we come back
we're gonna be talking about hip hop you
don't want to go nowhere we'll be right
back
[Music]
there's only one Jesus was his messenger
why did that maybe it maybe it's just a
break bi
Salam alaikum brother peace be on to you
while they go solanum to allah peace be
on back to you brother thank you brother
for being with us here again on the Deen
show my pleasure man thanks for having
me my pleasure man
now I mentioned hip hop and can you tell
us and define what is hip hop actually
mean
hip hop nowadays is very hard to even
define it because every year come up
with something crazy but I know on hip
hop started in the Bronx New York the
whole rap thing where I recall and
remember when rat first started off it
was all about trying to help each other
get out of the struggles of an inner
city and it started off with everybody
talking about we're gonna go back to the
motherland and Africa we're gonna help
each other but now hip-hop was way far
away from what it started from the
foundation of basically positive and
getting the people out of there and the
struggles of the inner city right now
hip-hop from what we know is all about
how many how much guns you shot how many
people you murdered how many women you
fornicated with disrespecting women and
disrespecting other people is basically
to the point where it's even hard to
define hip-hop as far as Marcus are from
what you just said here this is the
antithesis the opposite of Islam the
Islamic tension is so this stuff is
something we want to talk about because
it's prevalent today that the youth and
just people in general they seem to like
this hip-hop so a fortunately man I
think won the shade tahi beautified that
lifestyle where when a person turned on
the television they see these rappers
and as look and look as if they life is
just full of happiness they seem for a
five-minute video a bunch of cars
mansions money but they don't get the
CDs people behind the scene that most of
the people in the entertainment business
unfortunately there are some of the most
unhappy people in the face of the earth
even though their music videos might
display another characteristic of these
people but these people they not happy
and I was one of those people it was um
it's like the people are searching for
something to drink everybody's thirsty
and most of the people the italian two-
to quench the thirst you know what I
mean and I was right along with these
people yeah
you have your own section on the Dean
show where we did a show about how you
came actually to Islam how you
surrendered yourself to the creator of
the heavens and earth yes not his
creation definitely living the way of
life of all the messengers of God
including the last and final messenger
sent to mankind the problem how many
peace be upon all the messengers so now
tell us you were hanging around you were
a part of the outlaws yes sold how many
43040 records that sold 40 million
records were 40 million records outlaws
outlaws and Tupac he was someone who you
said is in a Guinness Book of World
Records in the Guinness Book of World
Records for selling the most records out
of all rappers he sold over 60 million
60 million records where why and
majority of the records he sold after he
passed away yeah so now you're Muslim
now muscle hamdulillah so now the life
that you live in is opposite of what the
hip-hop definitely people are calling
you to definitely hey partner April -
exactly most of the time hip-hop
unfortunately I wouldn't even truly
blame too much of the rappers the reason
why is because most of the rappers they
truly come from the ghettos so if you
come to an individual who never really
seen probably $5,000 in his life or $500
and you tell them I will give you a
contract for a million dollars I will
put $500,000 in your pocket but I want
you to talk about a certain type of rap
I want you to preach a certain type of
lifestyle in your music most of the
people gonna say you look man if I got
to talk about killing my own brother for
that five hundred thousand a million
dollars I'm gonna go ahead and do it so
it's a very it's an industry where the
people behind the scene is the ones
that's really calling the shots it gets
to the point where the rapper's if they
don't produce the album that the record
companies on to produce they out of a
job you know what I mean
so it's a very tricky cycle it's all
about cycle
get mined get yours I said effli it's
all about get up out of the ghetto
most of the rappers they never go back
to the hood they make it out and they
forget about the people in the hood so
it's a very tricky cycle you know I mean
even some of the rappers when they get
to a point when they get tired of that
type of lifestyle that this preaching
about any music is even hard because
they're in contract so the record labels
for example prints you remember the
singer named princess
reason why I used to walk around with
slave on his face because he he
basically exposed her industry it said
that their musicians are really slaves
to the record company what did he do he
walked her walk around and put slave on
his face he's walking around with
slavery trades Prince yeah the singer
formerly known as Prince I don't know
his name now but he's the speaker he he
talked about how basically this is a
record late this is an industry that's
is is designed to put you in debt
you put one record out and when you go
get your money they were saying with you
always millions and in order to pay this
millions back you got to give us another
record but we need this type of music so
it's really hard you know it means a
cycle that even some of the musicians
don't even know how to get out of it's
kind of like interest credit definitely
saying people run inches run a record
label show yeah so this is again the
opposite like we as those who follow
that way that way of submission to God
to the Creator
we want to be slaves to him but it seems
like if you run away from being slaves
to the Creator and you end up being a
slave to something in inspiration and
that's you hit it on the nail man they
basically you if you're not a slave to a
lot you're gonna be the slave to
something either your desires your money
your jewelry your cars you're gonna have
to be you're gonna submit to something
you know what I mean so the music
industry is basically a call to the
opposite of what Islam culture Islam
called for won the respect of women it's
it's Lomb culture that we do not oppress
women
you know before I became a Muslim I used
to oppress women you got people running
around saying that the Muslims we
oppress our woman I come from a society
man a background that I did music
oppressing the woman it wasn't until I
became a Muslim that you actually see
how a woman's supposed to be treated so
the music industry court said the
disrespect most of the limits is about
shirk associating partners with Allah
huh
this about like I mentioned yesterday
man I remember when I used to write raps
I used to literally try to inspire to
say the most evilest thing that a person
could hear yeah I used to go to write a
rap and I used to say to myself I want
to say something so evil that the people
might think the devil itself said these
words and this is the type of industry
that after a while it makes you want to
be the one that's the most and
everything the most craziest so the most
records the most disrespectful to the
woman it's a competition among the right
and we're dry what's the drive behind
that what are you trying to accomplish
shut the end of the day we'll be right
back former bad boy gone big boy ran
with an entrepreneur with an icon in the
music business how he obtains something
that money could take a bit about what
your fight was very good time to success
the directors that I did he left that
light wasn't a country that I couldn't
go through it lived his good life well
in the country I couldn't go through the
life that brought him peace without the
perfect person couldn't identify who I
was ready you're watching the TV show
together wait what are you waiting for
what are we waiting for right now what
are you waiting for all these people
that come to this line what are you
waiting for
what are we waiting for right now when
they're gonna come they're gonna come to
log on bring these people lost upon the
water put in our hand the ability to do
it now do your job
[Music]
the be honest on even when I look back
on it I ask myself what was I'm trying
to accomplish you know what I mean what
was I'm thinking about I think that it
was just this is an industry for the
devil I really think that this is an
industry for the devil witness is to
take people away from the remembrance of
Allah I mean so at the end of the day
the most thing at the end of the day is
all about money it's all about how much
records you sell how much money you make
what about some people that might argue
and say you know what this is an
artistic way of expressing oneself from
kind of the lifestyle that I used to
live now well you got people that might
say that and have you heard that I heard
that many at times you got most of the
people that you've got two groups of
people that say that you got the people
that's the non-muslims let's say that
where you gotta arm say well maybe they
don't have another way maybe they think
this is the only way then you have the
Muslim that say the same thing with we
should be ashamed because we we get our
guidance from the Quran and the Sunnah
and there's no way in our religion that
give us that the authority to go ahead
and use music to spread Islam if
anything the religion of Islam calls
against that do you not a man so I would
say to the people that is other ways to
express yourself you know what I mean
because most of the rappers if that's
the excuse that they expressing the way
they live with a society they come from
most of them don't even go to the hood
anymore so while you still disrespecting
women to this day when you've never been
in the hood you ain't been back to the
hood since you put a record out you know
what I mean you know what is your excuse
now so you mentioned because a lot of
the hip-hop and lot of the music
nowadays is like you said oppressing the
woman yes and talking about some of the
most evil things and murder drugs
drinking fornication and obviously if
you keep listening to this you're gonna
want to act it out exactly you're gonna
be a slave to this type of stuff if you
listen to this stuff and that's all you
hear like you just say it man eventually
that you've gonna start thinking that
this is the way of life you know the
mean growing up I remember that I
thought that that was the only way of
life you know what I mean so the best
thing to do we know that that's first of
all it's a waste of time
you know the main waste of time waste of
time to even sit and listen to that
stuff
second of all especially for the Muslim
youth we should know that this is we
have something better than music we have
the Quran you know so if you want to
listen to something to soothe your soul
what better way
tusu via so then the Quran listening to
the Quran yeah so so tell us Napoleon
from the Outlawz former member of the
outlaws that is a group made up by Tupac
Shakur yes selling millions of Records
living that fast life the dream and some
people are trying to acquire where you
got out of it was it difficult was it
difficult to leave this lifestyle no
doubt about it definitely definitely it
was one of the hardest things that I had
to face because all I knew was music you
know what I mean this is was this was my
life since I was a child this is the
only thing that I know how to do I'm a
high school dropout so I dropped out of
high school to go pursue my career in
the music industry and I started to make
money from this business so when I
became Muslim and I started to know and
read about and the brothers was bringing
me proof from the Quran and the Sunnah
that what I'm doing is wrong
eventually I had to get away from it and
it was very hard you know what I mean it
was hard because one I was getting the
devil would whisper to me and make me
start thinking well how am I gonna
provide for myself I'm a high school
dropout this is the only way I know how
to make my money second of all it was
just very hard because it was a dictate
lifestyle so for me to walk away from
something that I thought was the only
way of life and to find out the way I
was living was wrong it was definitely
hard oh you know how are you waking up
in the morning I I know a lot of people
who just set their alarm clock and hip
hop in the morning you afternoon
you got to burn your favorite CD 2012 in
the car all day all night
subhanAllah I was life it was my life
literally music was my life you know the
man everything revolved around music the
way it was my breakfast it was my lunch
it was my dinner so when I became Muslim
it was one of the things that I had to
ask myself okay this is the truth this
is the religion from the Creator that
happens in earth
this is falsehood only sad this is music
this is falsehood which one what side do
I rather be on and I know at this point
in my life there was no doubt about it
that I knew what Allah says in the Quran
was the truth no doubt about it so it
was one of them things that I had to
make a decision you know tell us now
because some people who are obviously
are engrossed in this they might say man
you know what this is a little extreme
you know what's wrong with music it
makes
feel good now let's rationalize this
from just a rational perspective for any
person with some common sense yes you
could talk about like the good things
that Islam was calling me to and the
opposite of what this music hip-hop was
calling me you might have some people
that might say is extreme but one as a
Muslim we try to live our life to the
best of our ability according to what
our lives messages tell us and the
prophets underlined they were selling me
say anything that will bring us closer
to that or leaders to the Hellfire he
warned us against it and anything that a
guide us to paradise he told us about it
how to achieve it so for example let's
talk about it for mine on Islamic point
of view perspective where you have
non-muslims that did a study on musical
instruments and even now Muslims
recently said that the musical
instruments affect the person body
physically they said that a certain
musical sounds you can listen to that
can actually make your heart skip a beat
and you can catch a heart attack they
said a serene music who sounds that you
can listen to that can produce some type
of anger inside of you and they said
it's uncertain musical sound that you
can listen to that even lead to
depression and they said they said for
example a lot of the rock and roll that
type of music they did a study and
notice that a lot of people that listen
to that music end up being suicide has
suicidal tendencies or they get
depressed
so if I laws in the message it told us
over 1,400 years ago to stay away from
this then we know is only good for us
it's not to harm us it's not to make our
life hard I mean or difficult it's only
to make it easy for us you know and it's
a true story that they just did a study
recently a lady that casts seizures she
falls out and catch fits so when they
play a certain sound certain music
records for her she's normal but every
time she listens to one record she
catches a seizure and fall out so now
the medical doctors the doctors are
saying that this is something in the
musical instrument that's harming them
physically to make a fall out and catch
a fit so we know that the musical
instruments can affect you in a way that
in a negative way do you not I mean then
you got some people that say well what
about some of the musical instruments
that we know like Beethoven and all
these people that you listen to and it
make you feel good
we know that Allah says in the Quran
about alcohol he said that even though
you might find some benefit in it but
the evil of alka trick and alcohol
outweighs the good so it's best to stay
away from me so you got some people that
might say well some good in it but they
know
everybody know that they evil music
outweighs the good you not as too many
is too many stories where you you don't
really hear incident where person said
listen to music today and and actually
really did some positive because I
listen to music were that were the
people now that you are working for the
owners of the record labels did they
really cared for the well-being of
humanity of course or not man the main
thing is about making some money the
main thing the people behind it saying
they'd only care what's going on D as
long as you're gonna sell some records
you're gonna bring them some millions of
billions of dollars they don't give you
the record talking about killing your
own mother for instance and my name came
out with a record he killed his mother
in the record buried and everything in a
record and in record labels produces and
promoted this type of stuff so I let you
know that they doesn't care about the
well-being of the producer musicians all
the people that's listening to the music
that's crazy stuff it's a crazy industry
and people are buying this department
people bought it his own mother Trotter
soon huh and because she she looked at
it like it wasn't entertainment she said
how come my son the record talked about
killing me and burying me but the record
label produce it and they promoted it so
yeah so obviously this is not gonna have
a good influence on our youth or even in
me they don't how about fifty cents now
you mentioned something about him not
drinking and not smoking since mentioned
that he doesn't he doesn't smoke
marijuana you know what I mean he's
smart enough to know that this stuff is
bad for you need to harm you but
unfortunately you got the youth that
they were listening to fifty cents and
they were actually trying to go get high
by listening to his music and they will
actually go pack a gun and they listened
to a certain rapper one of the thing
that the kids need to know that man this
is entertainment these rappers are
putting out these records talking about
drawbars these people don't even go back
in the hood anymore ninety nine percent
of them don't even go to the hood they
can't go to the hood
so it's an entertainment that the kids
they listen to these people and it's
something that they have to use their
common sense you know you should tell
yourself how come for example 50 Cent's
talking about all this gangster stuff
but he got the biggest house on the east
coast of America actually obviously he's
not in the hood anymore yeah so what was
your now suggestion I mean because
obviously this takes over a person's
life I mean you just you gotta get the
newest record that came out you got to
watch the you know the MTV
videos of all the rappers you maybe got
his picture on the wall I mean how can
you what what advice can you give to
somebody advice is basically man that we
won don't take these people as our role
models and that's for the muscle move
this is very this is sad because we have
role models from the profit selling line
they were settlement in sahabas these
are the people we take as our role
models these are the people that we
should look up to and want to be like
and trying to implement how they lived a
life but we shall look up to people that
have no guidance you know I mean me a
lot guide these people to Islam these
people that when they want to go feel
good they have to get higher you have to
go get drunk just the face reality of
their life when I was in the music
industry
man I was afraid to be sober just
because I know that the way I was living
my life wasn't correct and most of these
rappers on the same way man they're not
happy so why is our kids looking up to
people that doesn't that don't have
guidance you know I mean so it's very
important that the Muslim youth they
should know who our role models are and
we do have role models you got the
Muslim youth running around saying that
we don't have enough role models we have
role models just because we don't see
them on television does it mean we don't
have role models the Prophet southern
line they were selling is the best
example this is what I lost say it's you
not I mean this is the best example for
us to follow Charla
yeah so now you're away from that
lifestyle how is your life now how do
you feel my life now hum doodle are the
best you know I may never been more
happier more easygoing this is this is
this is the life you know I mean this is
the true life when you follow the
religion that the Creator sent down to
us life become easy and even if you do
get hard we do remind ourself that look
man I'm on a religion of the Creator
that I was in earth if you get hard so
what I have a chance to die and go to
jinusean also hamdulillah now when you
said hum did Allah for Allah okay please
do to God and so the people can
understand who are not Muslim what they
do to God yeah tell us because some of
the people think that religion is
something you know it's for the monks is
for the people who are kind of weird or
something it's not you something that's
you know I got time maybe when I get
4050 I'll turn my life around what do
you think about this thing one that we
never know when we're gonna die you
I mean every single one of us have to
taste death Allah says that in the Quran
that every soul shall taste death and
one Allah he's our Creator he knows
what's best for us if he the one created
us he know what life is best for us so
he is so merciful that a lot started
just creating us putting us on earth and
telling us to live life the way we want
to live life and figure out how to be
guided Allah so merciful that he sent
those prophets and messages to teach us
how we should live our life and what
better way what better person or what
better way to live our life according to
the person that created us he knows
what's best for us so we can never go
wrong following the religion of Allah
following the religion of the creator of
the heavens and earth so most people
might think that well following a
religion only gonna basically shorten my
I mean shorten the happiness of my life
but that's the wrong understanding
that's a misunderstanding because you
can never go wrong following the way of
life that you'll create a legislative
for you now as one who has consciously
made the decision to submit to the
creator not his creation yes worshipping
him alone not setting up many partners
sons daughters with the crater you got
all sorts of weird thing those are the
weird things and organized religions
organised by men we should have to
follow those but something organized by
the crater listen to it so now that you
have done that yes you submitted to the
crater yes tell us I mean for the youth
now who think that way of life is cool I
think this is the coolest thing knowing
your purpose in life tell us like some
of the things you do do you still play
ball do you still like you know hang out
with friends I mean I just locked up in
a room where shipping on that the people
think man if people think that the
Muslims don't have no life yeah but as a
Muslim well I he I swear to God that my
life became much easier more happier and
I seemed like I had more stuff to do now
that I'm a Muslim so it's many thing a
Muslim could basically life the way he
was living like before and pretty much
on sense of that you could still play
basketball you can still go hang out
with your friends you can go swimming
you can go horseback riding you can do
so much stuff that's permissible and
religion you think most people think
that as a Muslim all we do is go into a
dark room and just pray prayers that's
the wrong understanding of Islam yeah so
so instead of worshiping one of God's
messengers Muhammad Jesus mote you
worshiping the one who created them
worship the one who created them ascent
to us and instead of drinking alcohol
you drink fruit juice yeah I'll do exams
and you don't throw dice we don't throw
dice definite no gambling no gambling no
game we need a we don't need that yeah
it's only harmony isn't it Emily and
what what I mean we try to have them
relate to some of the goodness because
it's only in their nature if they honest
with themselves what's another thing I
mean you eat some good food right
definitely but you stay away from water
that's the food we stay away from the
ping pong stay away from the pig and
this it's a small amount of food that
the Muslims stay away from but other
than that I love everything is that
everything else he makes permissible
it's in like in this religion it's more
thing permissible that that's that's
permissible and impermissible you know I
mean this is the religion that it's a
vast religion it's a way of life a lot
of people don't know that Islam is a way
of life everything we do is pretty much
worship yeah I mean it's pretty much
worship and majority the people like you
said earlier they think to get religious
they life will get boring but that's a
wrong understanding and I was the same
way I was afraid that now I don't drink
alcohol how can I have fun I can't go to
clubs how can I have fun and you'd be
surprised that the stuff that you can do
when you live your life according to the
way you create a legislative form new
man life just become so much fun so much
happier then living that type of life
that you think is happy which is only
temporary happiness only temporary to
die at any time definitely dead now some
people think like man I got to give up
you know the bacon I got to give up that
Hennessy I got to give up the Jack and
Coke I got to give up fornicating I'm
losing my mind
but can a person now come in make that
first step
declare that there's only one god I'm
gonna worship Him alone except that
Muhammad is the last and final messenger
and then slowly some people say you know
I'll try to change all this then I'll
come to the way we did I think that
that's a bad understanding if they think
because if they think they should change
Dinka first because the only thing
that's when I actually changes is the
religion Islam that's the medicine
that's the medicine right there and the
most important thing of this religions
that we should worship our Creator alone
that's what Allah called us to the most
is that you should give him his rights
he created us he provide for us all he
acts it back from us is that we shall
worship Him alone that's the first step
a person should take that step first and
then later on they can work
my life and they can work a ball under
things but the first step that we should
take is to worship our Lord alone
give him his rights to know the man and
everything else come later you know even
the prophets underlined he was selling
for the first thirteen years he only
preached tawheed the oneness of Allah he
only called the people to Allah he
didn't it wasn't no verses of the Quran
reveal says stop drinking alcohol it
wasn't two thirteen years later you know
the man what I found in my personal life
is the more I got to know who my Creator
is you don't know then you like why
should I do these things from but when
you get to know you made some good
analogies yesterday that the crater in
one part of the world he's making it
shine and another part it's raining in
another part he's feeding the fish down
in the sea the bird in the air
wow that's amazing so when you get to
know your Creator and you want to do
what you want you want to give away from
this so you start feeling embarrassed
you start feeling a bad say wow look at
all the blessings a lot bestowed upon me
and he asked me to leave this for him
and I can't do it you know what I mean
so we can do what most people were
afraid because they think they can't do
it I mean that's another thing that if
you truly asks a lot of help you to get
rid of certain things or to get rid of
move away from certain habits Allah
Allah will make it easy you only I mean
from there you die in the right State
now you can be in paradise that's
forever forever ever man a paradise
imaginary with peril of forever that's
not worth you know taking something
that's so short you can die at any time
and bartering it for now Wow for
eternity who would do that nobody in a
right mind would basically take
something that's gonna last for 30
minutes five minutes to give up a way to
live in paradise forever yeah nobody
would do that any right mom I think it's
a blast comments and suggestions for
those now that they are really in tune
to what you absolutely what I was saying
man to the people that's listening I
would say if there's any non-muslims
aren't they listening man just take your
time up man it's not gonna hurt you for
you to go pick up the English
translation of the Quran and read the
bargain for the Prophet Muhammad and
also for the Muslim speaker to myself
first that it's about time that we
return back to our religion and
according to the Quran in the sender man
we go back to our religion properly you
know what I mean because there's nothing
else out there you know yeah and if you
can do it a person who was making a ton
of money here
and you sacrificed all of that gave it
up for the pleasure of your Creator is
nothing better than I think many of us
out there who are struggling with some
small vices we give that up you try it
man Tate try Islam thank you brother
yeah good thank you and thank you for
tuning in to the Dean show we hope you
got the benefit I mean take the advice
is real simple ask the one who created
you to guide you and then do some
legwork you did some legwork to get the
best car didn't you or to get the nice
clothes you had to walk to the mall you
had to you know put some effort behind
it I mean do a little effort and use
your mind open your heart and
investigate investigate and ask the one
who created you the guide you'd only be
fair if he did and come back here every
week to the Dean show calm we'll see you
again next time in sha Allah God willing
a Salaam alaikum peace be unto you it
comes to you the truth and the attribute
of the one who created you that he's one
and alone running this universe that he
doesn't become born he doesn't die he
doesn't eat and go to the bathroom this
is not God problem cares yeah is this it
doesn't make sense
who was Jesus worshipping as this is
recorded in the Gospels despite all of
the other issues about the gospel we put
those aside with the Saints mentioned
there with Jesus
from hunger
[Music]
[Music]
he created the universe to him along
heavens and the earth he is the first
he's the owner mercy eat them his
messengers to all these creatures of the
great dangers worshipping other than
Allah there is none greater
then the Creator
[Music]